have you ever wanted to import python
code directly from the internet like
from a GitHub
repo well now you can using the magic of
cloud
Imports forget the fuss of creating a
requirements txt and installing your
dependencies just import Cloud Imports
add your GitHub or other remote
repository and woo it just
works this is the real deal folks I
haven't secretly pre-installed this
prime number library in the background
if I remove the repo from cloud Imports
get an import error put it back and
we're back in
business there are absolutely no
downsides to running code directly from
the Internet it's fast it's efficient
it's bleeding edge and there are no
security risks whatsoever so for the low
low price of $39.99 a
month okay hopefully by now you've
caught on that this is a joke and
importing code directly from the
internet at runtime is at best a
horribly horribly misguided idea and at
worst a complete performance and
security nightmare but this code is
real it works it actually downloads
files from GitHub at runtime dynamically
creates modules and runs the correct
code you can use the inspect module to
see the source code and to your boss's
horror if you ask for the module's file
it gives you the URL where the file was
downloaded from so the real question for
this video is excuse me
what and to answer this very articulate
question
we need to learn about Python's import
system you're no doubt already familiar
with how imports normally work but did
you know that Python's import system is
accessible from python itself and it
allows you to customize what the import
statement does this is the purpose of
the built-in import lib to understand
import lib there's just three things you
need to know finders loaders and the
system
metapath the overview is that you
register finders in your metapath and
python tries each finder in turn until
either a finder succeeds or it runs out
of finders in which case you'd get an
import error if a finder succeeds it
gives a specification for the module
that includes the loader that should be
used to actually create the module then
python uses the loader to create and
initialize the module take a look at the
metapath as it is now the first item in
the metapath is a built-in importer
which is used for finding modules built
into the python interpreter itself like
iter tools CIS and time then there's
this Frozen importer which is used in
cases where the interpr is embedded into
a binary like if you're using p
installer you can ignore that for this
video and the third Pathfinder one
implements the usual logic looking in
directories in the system path which is
how python would find modules in the
current directory modules installed into
your virtual L and built-in modules that
were written in Python rather than
compiled Into The Interpreter like the
Json or inspect
modules all we have to do to get Cloud
Imports is to add another finder to the
metapath as a fallback for when python
wouldn't find the module any other way
that that's all this add repo function
does add another entry to the
metapath finders just need to implement
one method find spec which takes the
dotted name of the module and needs to
return a module spec if it can find the
module or none to let the next finder in
the metapath have a
try a module spec just holds the loader
and some extra info like the module name
and whether this module is a package we
implement the cloud finder by replacing
dots in Python Imports with slashes in
URLs and depending that onto the base
URL that the finder was constructed with
like the GitHub repo
URL we go out to the internet and
download those URLs and see if we find
valid python Source we check both forp
files as well as for Dunder and nitpy
files One Directory down so that cloud
Imports work with multiple files and
packages as long as they're written in
pure python if we find a valid python
file at one of the URLs then we return a
spec for the module that has a custom
Cloud loader holding the downloaded
source code in the loader we need to
implement create module and exec module
which are kind of like Dunder new and
Dunder init but for modules in create
module we create a blank module and add
it to the system module cache or we get
it from module's Cache if it already
exists in exec module we initialize the
module by executing the source code we
downloaded within the module's
dictionary this get Source isn't
required but it allows the inspect
module to find the source of the module
as well and that's it add some
convenience functions for adding
different kinds of repos and your
set zooming out it's surprisingly little
code under 100 lines to completely
change how python Imports work again
Cloud Imports are a mind-bogglingly bad
idea but I think understanding how to
write a cloud importer really helps you
understand how the import system works
and in particular how customizable it
actually is see the import lib docs for
more I'm James Murphy from M coding
where we do software Consulting check us
out at M
coding. as thanks for making it to the
end if you'd like a chance to win a
license to Jet brains IDE make a comment
including #m coding thank you to my
patreon subscribers and other donors for
supporting the channel slap that like
button an odd number of times and I'll
see you in the next
one